[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance in the span of one weekend a
man who essentially usurped the office
of President of the United States with
the assistance of this nation's most
powerful and venomous enemy has himself
attacked the structure of our Senate at
our House of Representatives because
their rules are archaic and they
inconvenience him has himself dismissed
the two-party system because he believes
it is obstructionist has himself
attacked the constitutionally protected
freedom of the press because the media
has repeatedly caught him lying has
himself let his chief of staff confirm
he may try to eradicate those freedoms
of speech and your freedoms of speech in
some this man has himself so endangered
the freedoms and the liberties of this
country
that if anyone does not understand that
they and you and I and every individual
in this country and everything we love
and everything for which every American
soldier has ever fought all of it is
under attack right now by this
crypto-fascist Trump if they do not see
that their freedoms hang by a thread
they are sheep headed to the slaughter
or collaborators leading the rest of us
there for the sake of Trump the failing
New York Times has disgraced the media
world John Carl of ABC said that as he
read Trump's tweet from March 30th aloud
gotten me wrong for two solid years
changed the libel laws to Trump's chief
of staff Reince Priebus mr. Karl
continued that would require as I
understand it a constitutional amendment
is he really going to pursue that is
that something he wants to pursue and
Priebus answered I think it's something
that we've looked at and how that gets
executed or whether that goes anywhere
is a different story but when you have
articles out there that have no basis or
fact and we're sitting here on 24/7
cable companies writing stories about
constant contacts with Russia and all
these other matters that have no basis
at all here mr. Karl interrupted to
refocus Priebus on whether or not Trump
should be able to sue
the New York Times Priebus quote and I
already answered the question I said
this is something that is being looked
at
wrong goddamned answer the correct
answer is that freedom of speech is the
purpose of the United States of America
and every time this country's government
has tried to alter that fact or has
ignored it in the slightest it has met
with disaster the correct answer is that
constitutional change to limit free
speech would not just be a step on a
slippery slope but it would be putting
the entire nation in an 18-wheeler and
driving at full speed down that slippery
slope the correct answer is never never
do not be sidetracked by Priebus
milquetoast disclaimer about whether
that goes anywhere do not be reassured
that at its worst this so-called
government would only attack the news
media do not settle down because a
constitutional amendment is the longest
of long shots this is about the threat
about the chilling effect as much as it
is about the execution Priebus started
by saying it's something that we've
looked at and then he upgraded his
threat to the present tense by saying
this is something that is being looked
at for the sake of Trump if as Trump
first suggested more than 14 months ago
quote we're going to open up those libel
laws it would not be the New York Times
or ABC News that would be the victims it
would be you the New York Times and ABC
News and the like could even in those
nightmare scenarios be able to defend
themselves legally at least for a time
would you if the libel laws were opened
up if writing or publishing a story the
government found was merely inaccurate
now subjected the writer or publisher to
a libel lawsuit with financial damages
or worse exactly who would then be a
writer or a publisher would writing a
blog post be writing or publishing would
sending a tweet be writing or publishing
what speaking at a protest be writing or
publishing armed with changed libel laws
Trump's target would be you what he
would stop would
be a newspaper article or a cable news
story that his supporters would never
read nor see nor believe even if they
were forced to look at it what he would
stop would be dissent what he would
create when his attacks on the media on
Twitter and at that white nationalist
circle-jerk in Pennsylvania Saturday
night what that little rat Priebus is
getting at is invoking fear inside you a
hesitation before you protested or spoke
out or wrote or tweeted or posted a
comment online that moment in which you
ask yourself is this going to get me
sued this technique has worked for Trump
all of his life family members ex-wives
business contacts customers the suckers
of Trump University lawsuit after
lawsuit the blight of financial ruin if
you violated his non-disclosure clauses
this is how Trump has gotten away with
nearly every crooked deal and every
broken contract and every threat to the
middle wife that nobody talks about
anymore because if she says anything
she and her Trump child could get cut
off or sued that's what Trump and his
minions like Priebus wants for this
country before you criticized even if
every fact is on your side they want an
America in which a voice inside your
head screams remember the government
could sue you for libel and keep you in
court with lawyers for years
indefinitely and even if you prevail the
government could ruin your life erase
your savings destroy your family and
that's if you win
and as you envision that nightmare
something else not to be missed in the
snarling little throwaway comment by
Trump's toady mr. Priebus what was the
first example he gave of what kind of
free speech needs to be erased you know
for the sake of Trump which topic just
happened to come up when phrases like
change libel laws and constitutional
amendment were invoked the first story
to which the Trump brand of fascism
turns the first story about which they
want to criminalize dissent is the Trump
connection to the Russians and that just
happens to come up as Trump invites the
murderous strongman of the Philippines
this pig
at a to the White House Duterte who said
last year quote just because you're a
journalist you are not exempted from
assassination if you're a son of a [ __ ]
unquote it's all coincidence no doubt
you look at the rules of the Senate even
the rules of the house Trump said on Fox
on Saturday it's really a bad thing for
the country in my opinion there are
archaic rules and maybe at some point
we're going to have to take those rules
on because for the good of the nation
things are going to have to be different
you can't through a process like this
it's not fair it forces you to make bad
decisions and now we change the rules of
the house and the Senate because they
don't move fast enough for the sake of
Trump because the bureaucratic delay
built into our system by the founding
fathers to prevent despots or foreigners
from changing our way of life overnight
is keeping Trump from changing our way
of life overnight on that two-party
system the right of the opposition to
exist that too has to be changed for the
sake of Trump
I also learned and this is very sad
because we have a country that we have
to take care of he said on CBS the
Democrats have been totally
obstructionist Chuck Schumer has turned
out to be a bad leader he's a bad leader
for the country and the Democrats are
extremely obstructionist all they do is
obstruct and you know what that's
hurting it's hurting the country change
the House and Senate rules for the sake
of Trump get rid of the rights of the
Senate minority even if they represent
the rights of the majority of the voters
in the last election for the sake of
Trump instill the fear that to speak or
write or tweet or ask what is this with
Russia will get you sued for libel with
the sake of Trump this man already as of
102 days in office the worst president
in the history of the United States
already the symbol of betrayal and
apparent treachery and the willingness
to [ __ ] himself out to whichever
foreign nation will give him a win in
the media or a win at the ballot box
this pitiful excuse for a human being is
a thug bent on destroying the freedoms
of this country as we know them and god
damn it we are not going to let him do
it resist peace